alarms go off all around the facility
things descended into chaos so quickly
of course the staff of the SCP
Foundation are extremely familiar with
the horrors of a Containment Breach by
now but this was something exceptional
two anomalies had joined forces in an
unexpected fashion neutralizing some of
the weaknesses that the two of them
usually experienced needless to say this
was bad more specifically 74 staff
members were dead already several
different mobile task forces had already
been dispatched to hunt down this
terrifying new anomaly but none of them
knew where it was hiding in the depths
of the site little did they know this
deadly new hybrid had already escaped
the SCP Foundation and was already on
its way towards a nearby population
Center that's where the real fun would
start but before we get to all that
Carnage let's rewind the clock a little
and find out how This Disaster started
some things just go great together like
peanut butter and jelly milk and cereal
or clicking subscribe when you're
watching a video by SCP explained but
for every match made in heaven there's
also a match made in hell like being
covered in sugar water while you walk
past a wasp nest or doing tricks with
your awesome Zippo lighter next to a gas
pump or most horrifying of them all a
combination of
scp-106 and
scp-035 of course the reputations of
these two horrible creatures are well
known and well feared enough on their
own
scp-106 is a humanoid Abomination also
known as the old man capable of walking
through walls and entering his own
private pocket Dimension where he
practices his pre-dilection for pain to
its full potential and then there's
scp-035 also known as the possessive
mask this is one of the most powerful
and dangerous psychic entities that the
SCP Foundation has in its vast
collection some of its more minor
unpleasant qualities are things like the
fact that it constantly drips corrosive
black slime or the fact it immediately
reduces you to a state of brain death
when you're foolish enough to wear it on
the more severe end of its abilities is
its power to crawl into the mind of
anyone around it slowly Whispering
Horrors into their mind until they're
completely under its control or utterly
broken it likely has designs on world
domination or at the very least to
plunge the human race into an
unimaginable pit of Eternal suffering
the one Saving Grace is the fact that
035's corrosive slime slowly destroys
the body of its hosts limiting the
purview of each one of its Reigns of
Terror but occasionally there are
wonderful terrible exceptions to the
rule speaking of terrible our story
began chronologically with scp-106
showing one of its rare signs of
activity this naturally caused waves of
panic to rock through the researchers
and security staff site they'd need to
grab a d-class then plug in and warm up
the femur breaker they'd also need to
mobilize groups of on-site guards with
powerful flashlights to slow the gnarled
old monster down but by now scp-106 had
gotten wise to the foundation's
techniques he wouldn't make himself so
easy to capture this time he wanted to
have the proper time to enjoy himself
scp-106 got up and faced through the
nearby wall his cell was never easy to
escape they filled it with strange
shapes and running water just to confuse
his wretched old mind but once he was
out he was out he avoided the hallways
instead just facing from wall to wall
until he reached a different block of
containment Chambers that's where the
Fateful meeting would take place it
wouldn't be the first time he'd wandered
into other containment cells his battle
with scp-682 perhaps being the most
famous but this time something was
different the room he just phased into
didn't contain some huge writhing
monster or another humanoid Beast it
contained instead a glass container on
top of a Podium the walls coated in
deadly telekil alloy to keep its
prisoners immense psychic power sealed
in but now that scp-106 was in the room
standing mere feet away from the
grinning white mask inside the glass
container there was nothing keeping the
two of them from having an extremely
faithful conversation the first thing as
cp106 noticed was the black liquid
leaking from The Mask strange it seemed
to perfectly match his own secretions
hello there good sir it is an often I
have visitors in here and even less so
visitors who are as handsome as you the
mask said speaking directly into the old
man's frail fractured mind I don't
believe we've ever been acquainted come
a little closer and remove the glass box
I'll be able to hear you better than way
come on come on don't be shy the old man
felt something about the mask was
distasteful even to a creature as
Despicable as scp-106 something about
the mask just seemed slimy
metaphorically as well as literally and
yet it found itself stepping forward
towards the glass case almost as though
he was sleepwalking how was the mask
invading his mind like this he'd always
been one of the more mysterious
creatures in the foundation's
containment and yet
scp-035 had slipped into his mind like a
warm bath on some level it frightened
him yes yes that's wonderful come closer
dear boy you're doing so well the mask
said as the old man reached forward and
began lifting off the glass case I think
I'd look rather good on you don't you
agree let's cover up that nasty old face
of yours you'll look positively spiffing
old jab just doing exactly as I say and
this is all going to go wonderfully the
old man picked up the mask somehow not
even in control of his own body anymore
and almost electrical power seemed to
pulse out of the mask and through the
old man's rotting fingertips the old man
was a sadist but he'd never before
encountered this kind of utterly
malicious intelligence this was a mind
geared to commit almost incalculable
evil and while the old man was wondering
how exactly he felt about that he was
already lifting The Mask up to his face
and watching the universe go very very
dark outside a small army of foundation
security operatives armed with
flashlights and assault rifles were
charging through the halls trying to
trace the movements of the old man for
recapture back in the old man's cell a
confused serial arsonist was being
shoved into the femur Breaker by a group
of nervous and impatient researchers
none of them knew they were dealing with
an entirely different beasts down here
now eventually the security team found
the last Rusty Scorch mark on the wall
of a containment cell belonging to
scp-035 before they could even
comprehend the terrifying implications
of this horrible scenario they charged
into the cell in hopes of stopping it
but by the time they were in there both
the Old Man and the mask were already
gone well not entirely suddenly the
guards in the room felt an odd sense of
calm wash over them not a true authentic
calm but an artificially induced one
like the lulling of a cattle while a
bolt gun descends towards their
foreheads the mask's psychic influence
had pacified them making them perfect
prey for the rotten hands reaching out
from the ground and pulling them down
into Oblivion the guards outside heard
the most horrific screaming they circled
the door terrified aiming everything
they had at the entryway but it wouldn't
be enough soon enough this new hybrid
Beast
scp-106 wearing
scp-035 emerged and began its Onslaught
it had the immense physical abilities of
106 bolstered by zero three fives
diabolical intelligence and ability to
Cloud the minds of its victims
inhibiting their capacity to run away or
fight back but most frightening of all
because scp-106 was already adapted to
resist the effect of its own corrosive
mucus it was also perfectly able to
sustain The Mask as a host without ever
melting and falling apart see what we
mean about a match made in Hell how do
you like my new body Gentlemen The Mask
asked its voice dripping with malicious
Glee it isn't much to look at I know but
you're about to get very well acquainted
with its collection of charming
abilities and The Mask stayed true to
its word it rampaged through the
containment site walting through walls
like a gleeful School child with a heart
and mind of Devil Himself leaving a pile
of melted tortured corpses in its wake
researchers guards janitorial staff
nobody was safe and with every killing
the rest of the staff became
increasingly afraid only strengthening
the psychic hold of the Mask it was
having the best day it could remember in
a long long time the site director and
his team put out a Mayday for all
available mobile task force units to
descend onto the area and help them deal
with this deadly new threat but by the
time they were on their way the mask and
its new scp-106 body had already had its
fun with the foundation even when they
activated the femur breaker nothing
happened the mask was far more
interested in the pain it could cause
outside and far too intelligent to be
lured back into imprisonment by such a
simple trick instead the hybrid made its
way out of the nearby perimeter wall
finding its way to a heavily armored
Foundation ground vehicle and sliding in
through the door like a ghost the
operative in the driver's seat was
immediately terrified by the monster
suddenly sitting next to it but then the
mask's psychic effects took over his
mind he became a calm Placid little
servant just like all those other Mortal
fools I feel like a change of scenery
old sport The Mask said to him take me
out to the nearest city it can be the
one of your choosing I feel like having
a little night on the town oh it's been
far too long you know the hypnotized
driver nodded and punched the gas the
guards were too busy controlling the
aftermath of the chaos within the sight
we even noticed the creature they were
chasing had already escaped and if it
reached a nearby City then the chaos
cruelty and Madness it was liable to
release would be the biggest mess the
foundation would need to clean up in
quite some time which was precisely what
the malicious mask had in mind meanwhile
Dr Robert Scranton woke up in a dark
room
well he wasn't sure if it was a room but
it was definitely dark he rose to his
feet in this strange black void
surrounded on all sides by Blackness it
wasn't the belly of scp-3001 the dreaded
red reality again no this was something
new and what's more he had no idea how
on Earth he'd gotten here Dr Scranton
said a cruel mocking voice behind him
turn around old jab it's been far too
long since I've seen you in the flesh
well in a manner of speaking at least
confused Dr Scranton turned and saw a
Vaguely Familiar sight
scp-035 the possessive mask floating in
the dark behind him what on Earth was
happening here he wondered oh you really
don't remember do you
The Mask said with a spiteful laugh
replying to a thought he'd never voiced
aloud they're in your mind doctor as it
turns out you're harder to erase than I
thought perhaps you're buried so deep in
the psyche of that monster
[Laughter]
I'll get you eventually how strange Dr
Scranton thought this must be his mind
playing tricks on him somehow he raised
a hand to scratch his head quizzically
and only then realized that his right
hand was gone simply vanished from the
end of his wrist The Mask gave another
sick laugh
oh it's already started I told you I'd
get you Scranton
the mask cackled with Glee I never
normally get to delete a mine slowly oh
this will be amusing where's Anna
Scranton asked suddenly wondering about
the safety of his beloved wife he
couldn't help but worry when this got
another cruel laugh out of the Mask
oh don't you remember Robert
The Mask said through Giggles
you killed her you killed her with your
toxic embrace
she died terrified of you and with that
all the awful memories came flooding
back back in the real world things
weren't any less horrifying and the
vehicle had finally made its way to the
nearby City the masked old man had
unceremoniously murdered at chauffeur
and decided to go for a little
exploration it had been so long since it
felt the sun on its pristine white
porcelain such a beautiful day outside
it couldn't wait to kill some people
around here it began its Rampage in a
dark alley snatching some homeless
people and unfortunate passersby through
the graffiti stained stone walls by the
time it was done with them there weren't
even any bones left but this would only
be the start of the masked old man's
horrific Rampage through the city next
he invaded an office building and
decided to unleash his Grizzly wrath on
the people within some were pulled
through the ground while chatting at the
water cooler others were dragged through
the walls as they went to refresh their
coffee some were simply sitting at their
desks getting on with their daily work
when a dark silhouette appeared behind
them some turned around saw the creature
and screamed immediately others remained
in ignorance and only screamed when an
acidic rotting hand curled around their
shoulder but every single one of them
screamed eventually by this point the
SCP Foundation had started sending all
the mobile task forces in the area to
the nearby city after receiving reports
of unexplainable disappearances and
murders Panic was starting to spread and
that Panic was only making the
nightmarish psychic abilities of the
Mask even stronger the challenge would
be intercepting scp-106 and removing the
mask before it became too powerful for
them to do anything about it if they
didn't they could be looking at a loss
of life on a massive scale which was
exactly what scp-035 hoped to indulge in
a young Barista was having a stressful
day at a nearby Boutique coffee shop she
retired to the staff bathroom to splash
some water on her face and re-center
herself she sighed and looked up from
the sink into the mirror to see if her
makeup was running and then screamed a
dark figure was standing right behind
her it looked like a rotting human
corpse dripping with black slime and
wearing a grinning white ancient Greek
comedy mask I'm not interrupting
anything am I the mass told man said
amused soon after the dark presence had
Spilled Out into the coffee shop the
psychic powers of the mass caused its
victims to be paralyzed with sheer
Terror unable to escape its cruel hands
the death toll of the day had already
risen to over a hundred and the masked
old man had no intention of stopping
that's when several police cruisers
skidded to a halt in front of the coffee
shop cops disembarked from their cars
and pulled out their handguns step out
of the store with your hands up one of
them yelled over a megaphone any sudden
moves and will blow you to Kingdom Come
This made the mass old man laugh
[Laughter]
oh how very adorable not long after he
was driving a police cruiser further
into town with a pile of Dead Cops left
in the street behind him this was
shaping up to be such a wonderful day he
never wanted it to end back in the pitch
dark of the mindscape Dr Robert Scranton
was looking a little worse for wear both
of his legs had disappeared along with
one of his eyes and much of the rest of
his right arm his remaining eye was
weeping remembering how his Embrace as
the old man had killed his beloved Anna
he lost his humanity and become the
worst kind of monster the kind who even
hurts the people he loves most
scp-035 floating in the darkness was
still just laughing at him
oh you're pathetic Scranton his it said
look how little is left of you
you haven't even been human in decades
why not give up what little is left
you're mine now
soon you're going to be nothing at all
and after Scranton kept crying because
he feared the mask was right back in the
city the stolen police cruiser pulled up
in front of a preschool and the masked
old man got out this would be the
perfect place for his next Little slice
of fun straining himself out he began
walking to the school knowing that with
the extent of his psychic powers nobody
would be strong enough to run away
they'd all just have to sit there and
suffer just like Dr Robert Scranton
Goodbye old man The Mask said to him I'm
tired of talking to you now Dr Scranton
was ready to give up and let himself
disappear but then something occurred to
him Knowledge from his foundation days I
I must be wearing you Dr Scranton said I
must be wearing you Scranton reached up
to his face with his remaining hand
grasping at something suddenly the face
of the floating mask Twisted into an
infuriated frown what do you think
you're doing it said it's too late
Robert but Scranton wouldn't be deterred
he gripped something invisible over his
face and began to tug even though
pulling on this invisible mask on his
face was agonizing the whole void around
him began to shake and quiver including
the grimacing
scp-035 Scranton just kept pulling stop
that you idiot it roared stop it stop it
stop it you're going to ruin everything
you but it was already too late Dr
Scranton murmured I'm sorry Anna and
gave one last yank that's when
everything went white back in the city
it thankfully wasn't long until a group
of mobile task force agents was able to
locate the two anomalies
scp-106 was sitting cross-legged on the
grass outside of a preschool where
thankfully nobody had been hurt and was
just staring off into space and his
Trembling Hands was another familiar
sight of frowning
scp-035 now go check out the whole story
what if scp-096 wore scp-035 and scp-106
the Old Man origin theories for more
Tales concerning today's terrifying
anomalies